it has been nearly three months since  metro lieutenant eric lloyd died of  complications from covet  today a special tree planting ceremony  held in his honor at the police memorial  park  the park is dedicated to memorialize  local police officers  who have lost their lives in the line of  duty lloyd's widow spoke on what was an  honor  this dedication is during what is such a  difficult time  along with all the other great names in  this park  that people see who have sacrificed  their life  [Music]  it's so humbling it's very humbling for  people just always to remember officer  lloyd was president of the injured  police officers fund  yesterday members met for the first time  without lloyd as their leader  the meeting focused on how the  organization plans to move forward  the injured police officers fund is now  focusing on covid19 prevention